and i i see that i say that even to my
own kids i tell them you know uh
do whatever interests you you know
whether it's martial arts music whatever
but
please focus on stem because i think
this is the future
you know
[Music]
thank you so much for joining me on 20
minute leaders how are you very well
thank you thank you for having me
thank you for inviting me to your
beautiful home we're here in dubai
uh salim start by telling me about this
painting behind us
because i think that it has a lot to do
with what's happening in this room right
now
in our dialogue well uh
let's pick up from the last word you've
just uttered
because that's actually the name of the
painting the painting is called the
dialogue
and it was commissioned
by a gentleman who used to live in dubai
15 years ago
by an artist who i had the good fortune
of meeting
20 years ago in london way before i
moved to dubai
and the commissioner
asked ralph hymans who is the
artist to paint something that focuses
on the region
but focuses on interfaith
and this is what ralphie produced what
is behind us
so why is it hanging on my wall if it
was commissioned by somebody else
so after six months were thereabouts
in 2005 when um
ralph completed the painting and he came
to visit dubai for the first time
we went to hand over the painting to the
clients who commissioned ralph only to
find out when we unveiled the painting
that he disapproved of the image having
approved paid everything prior to right
so he did a total vault of us
and um of course ralph was
you know crestfallen um i
certainly was gobsmacked because
in my world when you shake hands with
somebody and do a deal and
you don't renege on it but this was a
very influential person
in dubai at the time we gave him i was
one year old in dubai
i we gave him his money back and we
walked out
with our tails between our legs and then
at that moment i turned around to ralph
hyman's who is the you know the person
who
painted this painting called the
dialogue and
said ralph you know what i'm not legally
or contractually i said to myself
obliged but you know what i just felt
bad i said i'll buy it
so you won't have wasted your time ralph
never forgot that gesture
today by the grace of god i'm one of the
three people
in ralph's world who can actually
represent him globally
on his website ralph hymans.com to
to to handle his commission inquiries
he later went on to get his first royal
commission in 06
and then fast forward to 2012 uh
his first serious royal commission he
was the only artist commissioned by
buckingham palace to paint the queen for
the diamond jubilee
that painting for any of those who live
in london who visit london i
invite them to go to westminster abbey
because that's the final resting place
of her majesty the queen's painting
she's the totem factom royal in the
planet as you know
and that painting hangs at westminster
abbey today
[Music]
fast forward 2018-19
i was here in dubai and i was in karachi
and then i came back
in the new year in 19 and all the papers
were talking about a big event that's
going to take place for the first time
in this country
so what was the big event the big event
was
that pope francis
is going to visit the uae for the first
time
so we're all very excited you know
the holy see from the vatican is coming
to abu dhabi
he conducted a match he came for three
days during something called interfaith
harmony week
february 3rd to 5th he was only here for
48 hours the whole world covered that
event cnn reuters
bloomberg all the usual suspects and
um he conducted a mass for nearly a
hundred thousand catholic christians
this was amazing and the interest what
was even more amazing
was that every paper talked about two
words
that the pope was focusing on now watch
my hands what were the two words
interfaith dialogue and i've got tons of
you know newspaper articles if you want
you can read
when i saw these two words i went crazy
i said 15 years ago 14 years ago back
then
painting was done in dubai by this
artist
called the dialogue subject matter was
interfaith
now look how those words have now moved
coming out of the mouth
of the holy see right people came want
to know about this that about the
painting
i didn't do anything i just carried on
i love that fast forward this year
you know minding my own business
suddenly august the 13th we're all
reading if these two words abraham
accord
when i read carefully i
i had no words and actually
for the first time i uh
turned around and i said you know what
i'm prepared to even gift this painting
but to whom and for what reason well the
message of this painting
is not a message that i manufactured
it was a message that i stood by 15
years ago
at a time when there was no abrahamic
code right
correct correct okay did i plan the
abrahamic court no
i'm living here finding my own business
like any resident in this place
doing my best and uh
when i see the abraham accord i then
reached out
to one of the ministers here who
actually had actually invited ralph in
an official capacity
in december 2019
for some work and said you know what
i believe this painting
deserves a gift from
a leader here to netanyahu for example
they said at that time look the deal has
not been signed it's just an
announcement maybe it's a bit premature
i said i'm a nobody it's okay i respect
it
quietly i kept my head down no problem
early september his highness
abdullah bin zayed went to the white
house
in front of the whole world signed
abraham accord
again before he was going i reached out
to another minister i said
i think he should give it to trump now
again
there was no response and then i decided
you know what
i'll receive my offer i tried i cannot
force something whose time has not come
and i cannot manufacture something that
does not exist
but i know there was a message that i
stood by 15 years ago and with god's
grace
one day the whole world will hear about
it
today if somebody came to me and says
salim you want to sell the painting
go to sotheby's go to christie's go to
this i said no we don't needs other
beers or christies
i will ask you one question if you can
answer it i'll put a price on the
painting
so what is the question if you can put
a price on
peace between israel and its arab
neighbors i will put the price on this
painting
if you can i'm welcome i'm i'm listening
if you can do it welcome
so that's a lot of the story behind it
in fact
this whole journey what where i'm
sharing with you now was actually
aired for the first time about six weeks
ago
through a podcast that took place out of
new york
uh alex romano which runs a platform
called global edge talk
so a lot of this and the materials has
already been shared
wonderful but it's it's in the light of
you know the aftermath of the abraham
accord and
now you know the normalization of
relationships
between both sovereign states
you know um the story is now being told
for the first time
not even when ralph with all due respect
got the the commission from buckingham
palace i did not say anything
you know it's beautiful for ralph you
know he's a
today is referred to as a modern day
caravaggio anybody who doesn't know him
please go and check him out
if you want caravaggio today at not
caravaggio prices
go to ralph you know i mean you know
but that's not the point the point is
this has been a long journey for me
it's a very important journey in my life
and it's got nothing to even to do with
my main business that i came to do
in dubai you know 16 years ago it was
the start of this business in
looking for technology entrepreneurs
but today if somebody asks me saleem
what are your three passions in life
okay they're very simple now it's
technology
art as you can see around the house we
both my wife and i cannot and interfaith
dialogue right
interfaith dialogue to me is very very
important
i explained my background to you earlier
you know there were six flags i showed
you
right right you know the fiji islands
pakistan
nigeria uk japan and now united arab
emirates
you know uh i i can move between these
geographies
quite seamlessly i lived in africa
i grew up in africa i hail from pakistan
i worked 37 years with the japanese it's
a different culture
i'm now living in the ue for 16 years so
it's a melange you know a mixture of uh
different people different types and
that's why i look at life today you know
you have five fingers on your hand they
all belong to you they're all different
sizes they coexist
if god put all those five fingers and
they want it to be equal they'd be equal
they're not
but they co-exist so learn from your
hand lessons of life
saleem you have a fascinating upbringing
all the way from nigeria all the way to
going to do business in japan now in the
uae
with three more flags in between your
background is in mathematics
so you study mathematics yes i did in
oxford right in cambridge and and
yes transitioned from from academia to
there to becoming a problem solver
tell me a little bit about your mindset
like you did earlier about what it means
to be a problem solver whether it's in
mathematics or in life
or an interfaith dialogue well look
in life a mathematician
is trained to solve problems at the at
the basic at the essence at the core
so any mathematician worth his or her
assault
will learn uh keep trying and
have the ability to solve problems those
problems
uh uh obviously are
mathematical in nature however when you
go out into the
the big world there are other type of
problems that come about
but the problem and a problem solving
capacity or ability i see parallels
between them
it's the way your mind is hardwired the
dna
and i see that i say that even to my own
kids i tell them you know uh
do whatever interests you you know
whether it's martial arts music whatever
but
please focus on stem because i think
this is the future
you know and uh uh when i was 17 i i
told my late parents at the time
you know dad mom i want to i want to
study maths university and i remember my
my mother's words at the time she said
no you're going to become a teacher what
are you going to do
become a digital get a profession of
course a different generation a
different mindset i respect that
however my dad said one beautiful thing
he said let him follow his heart
today i am so grateful that he allowed
me to follow my heart when i was 17.
and today it's that mathematics that is
really really
the core the essence of how i look at
everything in life
i analyze i'm constantly running
simulations of things
you know when i meet entrepreneurs today
i'm analyzing them
literally from the minute they open
their mouth and interact with me
you know and it's going on it's like you
know the cpu of a
computer it's just running at the back
you know crunching
and this is what i do so i'm analyzing
you know they show me uh
five year projections and numbers and
this and that you know
you can analyze it very quickly
and it's not conceptually difficult
right what what we do now what i'm doing
right now in the
in the vc world is it's it's not
conceptually difficult
it's more commercial it's more uh
speed access people networks you know
but is it conceptually difficult no the
part three of the match stripe was a
date at cambridge
that was conceptually difficult this is
not when we when we're sitting back in
your office you were mentioning to me
we didn't even talk about the numbers
and the five-year projections you were
talking about sniffing the right
entrepreneur
smelling the right opportunity to
partner with the right person
not just their ideas and not just the
capital but but the entrepreneur
yeah tell me about that as your role as
as a one-man vc show because that is
what you are we we talked a little bit
about orange zev before
and one of the most remarkable things i
think about your journey that i'm so
inspired by is your outlook on
on the globality of things and how you
can and how tech
integrates all parts of the world not
just silicon valley in tel aviv and you
are
one of the people in the forefront of
that tell me a little bit about your
mindset
well thank you for asking that question
and i really appreciate it
and again i like to break things down
you know in
bite sizes so people can understand it
very easily
and answer that is very simple when you
go to a bar
you meet people you meet friends some
you connect with some you don't
correct what is that first exchange that
chemistry
that is taking place that connects you
with one person as opposed to somebody
else
before they even open their mouth
this is a human attraction there's a
human proclivity there's a human
affinity whatever you want to call it
and then
the guy opens their mouth talks exchange
ideas are being exchanged
some are you're receptive to some are
not so let's now take
that basic thing out from the example i
cited into the entrepreneurial world so
you meet an entrepreneur for the first
time
some people you will connect with some
people you will not the ones you don't
connect with doesn't mean they don't
have a good idea
the chances are as a vc this size
you know and you have 24 hours in a day
it becomes part of your
filtering mechanism the ones you connect
with
and then you like the idea that's a good
starting off point so i say
i only i'm agnostic to geography as i am
to industry vertical i only compare
i only care about the underlying
compelling
value proposition of the idea open your
mouth and appeal to my intellect
once you appeal to it i'll get engaged
once i get engaged doesn't mean i'm
right
i've had three companies that crashed in
my portfolio i've had three exits
i've had one company that's got the
backing and funding about tier 1 silicon
valley corporate vc sitting here in that
little office you came into in dubai
so this is my journey
this is what i do i connect with people
i connect with cultures i connect with
all religions
i connect with society and i'm not
saying it
i've done it i've connected with all
kinds of people
even way before the abraham accord that
is now official
i had many jewish friends some from
israel some
you know persian jews or you know jews
from
whatever you know i had a lot of friends
but it was never something that
i grew up you know saying oh that guy's
a buddhist that guy's an indian that
guy's a
jewish no it's not the way i was brought
up
i was brought up by my parents that's my
late father picture i'm pointing to over
there and
my late mother is over there you know
yeah
i i i was brought up to
respect people uh you know my dad used
to always tell me
son you take any two people in the world
and ask them how many hours in your day
answer 24 how many in yours 24. on what
basis is this time more valuable than
yours is the mathematical constant
first differential is zero how how can
your time be more valuable than his
and you take any five people in a room
all different nationalities one spanish
one indian one israeli one jewish
japan whatever you make a small cut in
their skin
if the color that comes out from any one
of those people is different
come back to me this is how i was
brought up
this is the fundamental tenets i use to
lead my life
i'm not impressed about money i'm not
impressed about
uh people who sit on billions of dollars
of funds
first it's not theirs and if it was
theirs okay
great with hard work i have no no
objections to that
but you tell me you manage a fund of
somebody else's money and
it does not impress you because that but
a great idea
i bound my head to that again another
quote from my late father
he said son you bow your head to two
things in life first and foremost your
creator
second in that order superior intellect
i've taken his words and i made a
business out of it
today the people i bow my head to are
the entrepreneurs
they're the smart ones not me so respect
the entrepreneur
and today with interest rates being next
to zero or negative
even the market doesn't value money
anymore so who am i to stand in the way
of that
what does the fund mean right i don't
know you're talking about buying your
banknotes
to the entrepreneurs and not not
necessarily the capital or or whatever
the status is but you're an entrepreneur
yourself you sold
your company yes you're that you
put your own capital right now outside
investments privately also
the the vc fundraiser that you own
yourself it's your own money in it
why why go that route why go the route
where you're investing in yourself
because it seems to be a big part of who
you are right well
perhaps it is you know i mean um
in life i i've i tried i tried working
in a corporate world
i i did well in a corporate world but
there was too much fun in the belly and
you know i was
uh running when everybody was walking
and i was walking when everybody was
sitting you know so it's who i am right
and uh um and i'm not here to impose my
views on anybody
i say you know people want to build
multi-billion dollar empires great do it
but i have my own journeys in life and i
also
am caught to my own beliefs and
part of that court of my own beliefs is
the
the uh i was also influenced by a book i
read by
todd henry uh die empty
i i believe that's where we all will end
up
you know you know the book i don't this
is important i think for your
fellow students and whoever you're
sharing this with somebody was asked one
day
where do you find the most expensive
real estate in the world
this is the theme of the book which has
really influenced
me and it said uh somebody said you know
tokyo
the imperial gardens somebody said
rockefeller center somebody said
you know buckingham palace wherever he
said no you're all wrong
that is not the most expensive real
estate in the world and you've got all
these big funds
buying real estate you know now guess
what kovit has done to it
we don't know it's not me i didn't do
covet you know
something happened but he said in this
book he said
the graveyard is the most expensive real
estate in the world
and the guy asked him why is the
graveyard the most expensive real estate
in the world
he said you know the number of people
with amazing ideas who did not share it
with the world
who end up six feet under what a waste
to humanity when i
started absorbing that
i said what's the point of chasing money
yes you need something to live eat
roof over your head there's enough in
this world for everyone's need
but certainly not enough in this world
for everyone's greed so it was a
rewiring of the brain
so i'm happy to do it on my journey if
somebody wants to join welcome
i i have a very simple philosophy in
life never say no to the first cup of
coffee i learned that
when through ralph actually the artist
20 years ago
because my mind was focused in japan
trading and anything that was out of
that world i didn't want to
no keep an open mind meet people
try different experiences different
cultures eat different food you know
spend time traveling when once kovit
allows and you know
things normalize a bit and this this
gives you a much
better rounded balanced view of life
but this is the way i've been brought up
i love it salim this was
uh inspiring thank you for sharing your
with sharing
sharing with me your journey your
passion both for technology for ideas
but but also for interfaith dialogue
i really didn't expect this coming in
and i think it's it's remarkably
inspiring for me
as i'm ending here on my trip in dubai
this past week to
to have this as the final conversation
it leaves me with inspiration hope and
and mainly excitement to come back and
welcome any time and welcome anytime and
really impactful things together so
thank you very very much
shalom shalom and the very last thing
that i have to ask which is the most
important question
three words that you would use to
describe yourself i have a feeling i
know some of them already
and i have a feeling you mentioned them
already but but three words that
anybody who would who knows salim hassan
would would
say about you well i think first and
foremost it would be passionate
yeah you know persistent
and persevering those are the three p's
that
guide me in my life i never give up to
anything if i fundamentally have a core
belief in something
nobody can change my mind wonderful
other than an act of god who is my
the ultimate the ultimate my creator and
who's least my life
to me our life our lives have been
leased to us
we don't even own that so we don't own
that how can we
put claims on other things when our own
the most precious thing we don't even
own
you know it's a fundamental
philosophical way of looking at life
right and because of that then you
suddenly realize you're just a
you know a tiny little speck you know
and
uh it puts things into perspective
you know and to me to me to me
i never like to talk about it but it you
know it
there's a wonderful poem that um
when i was 15 i learned by the guy who
wrote pilgrim's progress called john
bunyan
it's called contentment again this poem
influenced me in my life when i was 15.
and i
recommend anyone to google and just
check it out
if they're not already read it and i'll
just read the first stanza for you
you know it's he that is down needs fear
no fall
he that is low no pride he that is
humble
ever shall have got to be his guide that
first stanza you know has influenced me
in my life
nothing wrong with being down and low
you will never fall
you will never fall in life
you can only fall when you rise
and you'll fall when you rise because
you know certain things overtake those
basic tenets that you lose
track of as you're rising if you don't
lose it you will continue to rise
i love it salim thank you very much
you're welcome this is wonderful